San Francisco cured racism
cure it they're going to give black
people five million dollars
and then it's cured I hope San Francisco
reparations committee proposed a plan to
City officials last month that would pay
long-time black residents of the
northern California Metropolitan City 5
million dollars each well granting total
debt forgiveness for decades of
systematic repression I have to remind
you I don't know if you're a history
buff or not but when you look at slavery
and the history of California one of the
funny things is California never had
slavery
it's one of the most notable states in
the country that never had slavery
because in fact the slavery question
into California was one of the causes of
the Civil War which ended slavery over
150 years ago so people in California
who were never slaves are gonna make
five million dollars each paid for by a
state that never had slavery